[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire de la cité bijoutière
commence ici en plein coeur de
saint-amand-montrond rude et l'île
prison pierre medinski écrivain local
s'est penché sur cette période
à la fin des années 90 c'est la première
fois qu'il entre dans les petites pièces
qui accueillit les ateliers d'orfèvre
alors j'imagine bien ce que c'est de
faire des trucs avec de la fumée dans
des petits rats coin pareil mais ça
c'est des atelier de bijoutier qui
gobent comme comme les décrit zola dans
dans l'assommoir c'est les travailleurs
en chambre le premier atelier de
bijouterie et créer ici par les frères
maurico en 1890
de cette époque il n'y a aucune
représentation
il ne reste que des appartements à
rénover et les récits qui se
transmettent de génération en génération
sur l'arrivée des deux bijoutiers
parisien a fatalement on venait de
légaliser l'existence des syndicats et
bref les des ouvriers les mots rico ils
étaient près de paris il n'était pas
très disciplinés les dix ans et il
cherchait les deux frères chercher un
une ville à la campagne petite ville à
la campagne bien sage une population
bien inoffensive pas d'un art schiste
pas des scarpe capable d'embarquer des
lingots
c'est parti pour des années de balade
matinale de l'or entre la gare dorval et
les ateliers un homme de confiance des
bijoutiers se rend à la gare en carriole
puis à vélo pour récupérer les lingots
d'or emballés dans des caisses en bois
jusqu'à 20 kg d'or sont transportés
ainsi discrètement chaque jour très vite
les frères mûri qu on ouvre une fabrique
à la cotrel au bord du canal de berry
qui emploie jusqu'à 200 ouvriers puis la
bijouterie gagne toute la ville et ses
alentours
quelqu'un qui était contremaître qui
était capable tobin qu il devrait à son
tour une fabrique de bijoux c'est comme
ça qu'a st-amans soult vrai sans arrêt
des des nouvelles fabriques dans des
nouveaux endroits et d'après les fab
disparaissait ou où se fusionner mais
c'était une pépinière d'une pépinière
d'ouvriers saint-amand-montrond au coeur
du boischaut nichée entre la marmande et
le cher compte 10000 habitants
rien ne prédestinait cette petite ville
de vignerons et de paysans à devenir une
cité bijoutière et pourtant elle sera le
centre le plus importante de la
bijouterie creuse en france
[Musique]
jean-claude seul cas a bien connu cette
belle époque horlogers et bijoutiers
il a quitté l'alsace pour ouvrir sa
boutique saint-amand surnommé le petit
paris dans les années 70 saint-amand à
l'époque c'était l'eldorado parce qu'il
y avait du travail avait il y avait
énormément de enfin une activité
économique commercial qui était très
forte
il y avait des boutiques de luxe
chaussures de luxe vêtements de luxe
d'ailleurs il y avait beaucoup de
clients qui venaient de bourges acheté à
saint-amand saint-amand fabriquer 4
tonnes de bijoux en or par an 1,4 tonne
c'était le le troisième centre de
production en france pas de pacotille
chemise ouverte
shammam or qui brille rappelez-vous les
années 80 affiche et ses bijoux en or et
tendances et les entreprises de
saint-amand en fabrique au kilomètre
à cette époque dans le berry près de 500
salariés consacrent leur journée à leur
spécialité la macreuse en or 18 carats
jean-claude sur le cac garde un souvenir
amusé de cette période
pendant donc vous avez le palmier le
collier pamiers en chute
on le faisait aussi en choquer la
fameuse gourmette américaine
si la ménagère de plus de 50 ans à
l'époque n'avait pas à bras c'est comme
ça c'est qu'elle n'avait pas réussi sa
vie où le mari n'avait pas réussi sa vie
tirée du fil d'or est devenu un geste
rare à saint-amand à 46 euros le gramme
le métal précieux se vend de moins en
moins aujourd'hui
le bijoutier passe plus de temps à
racheter de l'or à ses clients qu'à
fabriquer des bijoux avec je fabrique
oui quand j'ai des demandes
particulières mais de moins en moins de
moins en moins parce que bon l'or est
trop cher et c'est donc du fait que
c'est trop cher c'est puis la mode
et puis nous sommes pas dans une région
bien que j'ai quelques clients parisiens
nous ne sommes pas dans une région
étaient porteuses économiquement et pour
le bijou et pour autre chose derrière la
flambée du prix de l'or et la
concurrence étrangère s'invite dans
l'histoire le début du 21e siècle c'est
aussi la fin de l'âge d'or de la
bijouterie à saint-amand il ne reste que
trois entreprises qui emploient une
centaine d'ouvriers dans ses ateliers
très discret dieu sait que la
municipalité de saint-amand a fait
beaucoup pour pour maintenir pour
maintenir des fabriques parce que
lorsqu'une fabrique fermé ça m'était
atteint d'ouvriers sur le carreau et
quand vous êtes un bijoutier un ouvrier
ultraspécialisés si vous allez faire
d'autre
alors en 2000 en pleine crise de la
bijouterie la municipalité érige cette
pyramide à 9 millions d'euros
l'objectif sauver les métiers d'art et
les derniers orfèvres
[Musique]
j'étais vraiment les ateliers ou en fait
les c'était vraiment réservé aux
professionnels et quelques cas de
personnes qui venaient mais c'était pas
une boutique en fait trois artisans
d'art s'installe des expositions sont
organisées
mais les entrepreneurs orfèvres
rechignent à s'installer près de la
pyramide
le projet de créer un paul delort échoue
l'objectif de tous ces gens dans la
joaillerie c'était de ne pas ne pas
communiquer s'il ya un côté quand même
très discret voire secret donc c'est sûr
que rassembler en un seul point des
centaines de kilos d'or c'est pas en
le sort semble s'acharner sur la
pyramide des cambrioleurs prive le musée
de l'or d'une partie de sa collection le
fameux lion de kuji s'envole la cité de
l'or devra se contenter de rester une
salle de spectacle
cette pyramide franck domin l'enfant du
pays devenu geôlier qu'il a bien connu
après 15 ans passés à paris il y a
ouvert son premier atelier à l'époque
c'était un peu considéré comme une
pépinière d'entreprises moi ça m'a
beaucoup aidé est-ce que l'endroit était
très sympa très luxueux et ça va pour
recevoir les premiers clients de paris
c'était super aujourd'hui l'artisan
d'art est installé en plein centre de
saint-amand il compte parmi ses clients
des grandes maisons comme dior et
quartier ont fait aux 50% particulier
50% mais ça nous permet de pouvoir en
vivre
on cherche pas forcément à venir une
très très beau société lui ce qu'on veut
c'est ce plaisir est plutôt le des
pièces au diable pour se démarquer de la
concurrence étrangère franck dôme 1 à 2
secret le premier c'est son associé
meilleur ouvrier de france spécialisée
dans le polissage un métier de plus en
plus rares quand on fait du polissage en
joaillerie on travaille effectivement
avec les la machine que vous voyez là
avec des desbrosses qui sont rotatif qui
tourne sur un tour à polir mais surtout
on travaille avec ce type de chose qui
s'appelle des fils de jacques audace ans
donc il ya différentes différentes
tailles différentes formes et en fait ce
qui va nous permettre d'enfiler toutes
les parties que qui ne se voient pas
qu'ils sont à l'arrière du bijou donc
c'est tout les petits carrés ce qu'on
appelle les mises en pierre pour pouvoir
faire ressortir l'éclat des pierres
quand on vient les certes sir alf
second secret de longévité
l'investissement dans les nouvelles
technologies gravures et soudure au
laser mais aussi imprimante 3d et
création assistée par ordinateur sont
devenus des outils indispensables en
haute joaillerie
il ya une dizaine d'années on a vraiment
été obligé de s'y mettre les marques
nous ont imposé donc moi je n'avais pas
appris ça forcément l'école j'avais un
ami de promo produit est elle vraiment
pu caler sur l'un sur l'infographie s'il
met à son compte les enfile ans à la
rochelle le la personne qui fait le
cerveau fait ça depuis 20 ans est un des
pionniers
même s'ils étaient moins bons mois entre
guillemets à la cheville ils pensent
exactement comme moi vous le dit
justement quand moi et ça c'est hyper
important
la plupart des grosses sociétés qui vont
des infographistes ses déhanchés un joli
les bases de son métier
franck domin les a apprises ici au lycée
professionnel jean hédou à saint-amand
depuis sept ans il enseigne aux jeunes
les secrets de sa spécialité
quelqu'un elle aurait demandé 2 mai
férié alliance d'accord qui on avait
demandé a ainsi atteint autour de doigts
et je devrai fait croire la dernière
heure le client s'était dopé
les joueurs avaient fait leur rodage
créée en 1968 jean guéhenno et le plus
grand lycée professionnel d'europe en
termes d'élèves formés en bijouterie et
d'élèves primes et angelina à tout juste
15 ans filles de bijoutiers elle a
choisi d'apprendre ce métier pour la
précision et l'exigence
quand on n'arrive pas ou quand on
commence à s'énerver il faut faut quand
même prendre sur soi enfin quand on fait
une belle pièce après on est fier de soi
par exemple cette pièce n'utilisait des
chutes de métal donc on a des po il ya
plein de chute et à partir de pièces
toutes plates
il fallait mais pour mai et où si
émerisé pour que pour lui donner la
forme oui mais parce que j'ai un peu
galéré
du coup bah oui c'est ça tu as
l'impression de voir mieux mais tu as
forcément aller à loix 3 bush
3 pas quelque chose de précis le lycée
bénéficie encore d'une belle réputation
mais voilà des formations ont bijouterie
naissent dans des villes plus animé que
saint-amand
du coup le sait à peine à recruter on
s'aperçoit que tous les ans sur une
capacité de 60 élèves en cp on ne
remplit n'y jamais jamais jamais la
totalité
donc il fallait absolument s'adapter ce
qui veut dire que pour la rentrée
prochaine
donc on va ouvrir une troisième voie une
troisième possibilité c'est à dire le
polissage ce qui veut dire que nous
sommes donc dans l'établissement 3 3
possibilités en bijouterie la joaillerie
le sertissage et le polissage et nous
serons les seuls en france à proposer
ces trois options si le fait happer
manque de candidats ce n'est pas le cas
du nouveau diplôme des métiers d'art et
du design le lycée propose 15 places
niveau licence pour une formation
complète d'artisans d'art en trois ans
les étudiants sont issus de filières
diverses
lové à un bac en arts appliqués elle n'a
pas suivi le cursus bijouterie ce qui
est vraiment important c'est de
justement trouver des solutions pour se
monter nos problèmes parce que tu es
content quand on arrive sur un problème
technique qui se dire bon bah c'est pas
possible on met de côté c'est pas une
bonne idée
l'intérêt de des métiers d'art et c'est
d'aller trouver comment surmonter cette
difficulté comment créer avec ces
difficultés là aussi peut-être au niveau
des fai être plus prononcé pour avoir un
véritable que la lumière accroche plus
forme des créateurs des formes des gens
qui s'ils vous innovez qui vont
expérimenter qui vont découvrir
s'approprier la matière ils vont
s'intégrer dans ce monde
ce nouveau monde et ils doivent faire
leur place tous les diplômés ne seront
pas artisans d'art certains
travailleront notamment pour l'armement
friands des compétences des bijoutiers
une chose est sûre la quasi-totalité des
290 jeune trouvera un emploi
on ne va pas transmettre simplement des
gestes on essaye de transmettre une
sensibilité et ça dans nos métiers
manuels cette sensibilité il faut être
dedans il faudra au contact l'histoire
d'amour entre saint-amand-montrond et
les métiers d'art ne s'est donc pas
terminé avec la fermeture des
entreprises de bijouterie locale elle
perdure à travers les nouvelles
générations qui devront être plus
mobiles et formés aux nouvelles
technologies elles arriveront sur le
marché du travail avec un atout majeur
un savoir faire qui se transmet à
saint-amand-montrond depuis plus de 130
ans
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]